[Music]
oscillation acting returning officer for
the Malcolm and loons Dale parliamentary
constituency declare that the total
number of votes given to each candidate
was as follows Robert Wilson Gillespie
UK Independence Party 1333 David Thomas
Morris the Conservative Party candidate
20 1773 Matthew James seven Liberal
Democrats 1699 Kate Sinclair Green Party
[Music]
478 Vicky Irene
singleton Labour Party 20,000 374
[Applause]
therefore I give public notice that
David Thomas Morris is duly elected as
the Member of Parliament for the Morcom
and linsdale constituency the total
number of votes cast across more
commanding cell at the UK parliamentary
election on 8th of June 2017 was
forty-five thousand seven hundred and
twenty nine the total number of ballot
papers rejected was 72 the ballot papers
were rejected for the following reasons
one ballot paper was rejected because it
did not bear the official mark three
coloured papers were rejected because
votes were given for more than one
candidate to ballot papers were rejected
because there was something written are
marked on the ballot paper by which the
voter could be identified 66 ballot
papers were rejected because they were
unmarked or void from certainty a
congratulations
[Applause]
I will sincerely like to thank returning
officer for what I think has been the
finest count I've ever been to here in
Lancaster the best organized I would
like to thank the security police I
would also like to thank the tellers
it's been a very long evening I don't
know about you but I've been up for over
24 hours I'd like to also thank my team
there are too many names I'm looking at
you all now and they're too many people
that aren't here but I would personally
like to thank Judy and Eric Hema who
sadly could be with us this evening I
thanks a lot of people what has happened
this evening I think every political
party should be taking note I also think
a lot of lessons should be learnt but I
shall carry on looking after the people
Malcolm I shall carry bringing them
seung-hyun I shall carry on bringing
them more prosperity
and I shall carry on doing my job as the
best MP Morgan Williams dell has ever
seen ever in the history of this seat
thank you very much